it's not the outright majority the
scottish national party had hoped for
but the election has produced a majority
for independence
with the snp bolstered by the greens
first minister and snp leader nicolas
sturgeon made clear what she intends to
do with it
both the snp and the scottish greens
stood on a clear commitment
to an independence referendum within the
next
parliamentary term and both of us made
clear
that the timing of a referendum should
be decided by a simple majority
of msps in the scottish parliament
pandemic recovery is the immediate
priority
after that the plan is for the scottish
parliament to legislate for a referendum
to take place within the next five years
it'll be for the government in london in
charge of uk constitutional affairs
to agree negotiate or challenge it in
the supreme court
a spectacle that would risk inflaming
separatist desire
even further so right now polling
suggests perhaps a slight slip
and not support for independence looking
kind of 48 49
um but it's been 50 consistently over
the last
year one thing that makes that would
make this referendum different though is
that there's not a whole lot of people
who are
undecided there's not a whole lot of
people who haven't made their mind up on
independence
so you would have to change minds rather
than
rather than enlighten people or bring
people together so you would have to
have to change their entrenched
positions which might be more difficult
prime minister boris johnson has
consistently ruled out a second
referendum
the first in 2014 was lost by a 10-point
margin
something he believes should have put
the issue to bed for a generation
but then brexit happened which scotland
voted against by a large margin in 2016
being taken out of the eu against their
will as many see it
has reinvigorated the drive to leave the
united kingdom
what it all serves to demonstrate this
election
intervening events since 2014 the
declining influence of unionist parties
scottish labour and the conservatives
is just how divided this country now is
split
pretty much right down the middle there
may well be
a path to a second referendum now but
still no
way of predicting the outcome if it
happens
and with its politics set to be defined
by antagonism towards westminster
and the pursuit of independence from it
for years to come
jonah al jazeera edinburgh